if you want to learn how to set
boundaries use the right tools and plan
your day then this video is for you and
one of the gaps that entrepreneurs is
that they feel like because they own
their day they can spend it like they
want you cannot spend it like you want
to
they say that hard work won't kill you
but I don't want to take the chance so
no matter how late at night you go
before you wrap up just take four
minutes and really think through
everything that you have to get done for
the next day what's that believe in unit
7 my one word is believe and I believe
in you I believe you have an amazing
gift inside you that I want to see
explode out onto the world so to help
you on your journey today we're gonna
look at eight proven ways to work
smarter not harder enjoy coming up at
number one is set boundaries with Eric
Thomas I have a ritual where even if if
you and my closest friend I have
boundaries so just because it's my
company it doesn't mean I can take calls
all day right I have boundaries so you
can't call me in a certain time why I'm
working so I'm on the phone all day to
be and I'm saying it's time to preneur
because one of the gaps and we'll talk
about this later in the show but you got
to find a gap and one of the gaps that
entrepreneurs is that they feel like
because they own their day they can
spend it like they want you cannot spend
it like you want to you so if you were
working for IBM or you're working for
for where are you're working for you
could be on the phone all day at a major
corporation talking on the ball so so
why do you allow yourself to talk on the
phone is your business my back is yours
you should probably you should make sure
there's no phone calls board over your
business so one of my rituals is when I
get started
there are no interruptions when I get
started I don't care if it's my wife my
children they know that from a certain
time
I'm going all in and I can't go all in
and answer the phone I can't go all in
and watchin TV in the strike head I
can't go in with the distraction and so
some entrepreneurs like why I brought up
because you don't you're not in
abstraction you don't have that that
that moment of your day I don't care if
it's two hours four hours where you shut
in try your world out no Twitter no
Facebook no you know no Instagram we
love that so we're just the two hours
I'm going in and once I come out then we
can do Instagram I'll be honest your
content probably would be stronger if
you had that that time of isolation of
solitude where you give yourself a
chance to think you give yourself a
chance to go in and when you go in you
go 120 percent so yeah I like that
number two is used to write tools with
Tai Lopez and then mount and guys like
Warren Buffett I mean he says he loves
quoting that one quote I don't know the
exact quote I should have memorized it
but he goes they say that hard work
won't kill you but I don't want to take
the chance I think that's how it goes
and he quotes that and and he says I
pretty much sit around all day looking
for opportunities and since 1965 I think
51 years ago they've made 25 good
decisions that are made almost all their
money so on average every two years they
were able to find so what he spends all
his day doing is reading and looking you
know being being observant so I do think
you have to be aware but hard work is
very uncorrelated with wealth and it
will get you it's the biggest you know
so I was talking about there's a lot of
people out there giving business advice
about working hard a lot there's not one
there's some more than others but Alex
Muir says his theory he calls it what
did he call it little mind theory or ant
theory that basically it's a primitive
impulse that if you say to people you
know what working hard is gonna get you
far it is with our primitive mind
because 50,000 years ago it was true
there was no technology
the man who you know hunted with a spear
but even then the one who had a spear
versus the one who just used his hands
still one technology's been beating
everything so what actually is
correlated wealth is using tools before
most people are so you want to look for
tools to me social media is just a tool
just like a caveman who had his bare
hands versus a caveman who came up with
his first spear or if he study history
had the Bronze Age and things like that
and it during those ages we'll look at
the Incas have you ever read the story
not Pizarro but who was the one who went
to the Incas not Magellan but one of
them you know he it was what thirty
soldiers that beat a hundred thousand
Native Americans they had horses and
armor and they just they decimated a
whole it was like twenty five men
that's how if you businesses war right
you want to be like that let other
people have a hundred thousand people
and you won't burn yourself up number
three is work in 90-minute chunks with
Robin Sharma
the myth of the harder I work the more
productive I will be is has been
debunked by the science if you study
human performance just what they've
realized that Jim Lehrer and Tony
Schwartz have done some great work in
this field but here's what the science
says optimal performance and
productivity happens in 90-minute cycles
so what am I saying
work for 90 minutes and then take a
break to recover then will from not
another 90 minutes and then go for a
walk and then work for another 90
minutes and then take a drink of water
and then work for another 90 minutes and
maybe take a nap or read something
interesting that's not related to what
you were doing what will that do it will
keep your mind focused on the work at
hand it will increase your energy
because energy is like it well you
deplete it you need to fill out the well
again and it will really keep you and
your productive s and also keep you
inspired rather than getting burned out
number four follow the 80/20 rule with
Brian Tracy when it comes to making your
daily to-do list make sure that you're
working from the 80/20 rule if you have
10 items to do on your list two of them
will be more important than the other
age put together you can do this by
asking yourself if I were to be called
out of town for a month what is the top
of twenty percent of my tasks that I
must accomplish today by knowing how to
prioritize tasks and working from a list
you increase your productivity and
output by twenty five to fifty percent
each day after you've made your
effective to-do list make sure that you
create time blocks dedicated to each
task keep in mind that new tasks and
responsibilities will come up
continually phone calls will come in
emails will need to be dealt with and
meetings will need to happen the key to
working smarter is also setting aside
chunks of time for those unexpected
tasks that will come up scheduling your
time this way reduces stress and makes
you feel in charge of your life number
five learn to delegate with Richard
Branson
the next stage is you know is to be a
great delegator and not try to do
everything yourself try to find people
who are better than you all the time try
to find people are better than you to
put you put you out of business
effectively so you know whatever you're
spending all your day doing try to find
someone who's better than you to do that
to replace you at it so that you know
you can go off and you know think about
the next big picture you know an
entrepreneur is not a man I'm not a
manager I mean an entrepreneur somebody
who is great at conceiving ideas
starting and starting ideas build
building ideas but then handing over to
really good managers to manage the
you know the moment you've got more than
one business you can't be hands-on doing
everything number six
manage your emails effectively with Tim
Ferriss how do I deal with email
overload there are a few tools that very
much help for this so the first that I
would mention is a tool called boomerang
what boomerang allows you to do is
schedule automatic follow-ups so you
don't have to remember to check if
someone has replied for instance and you
can set parameters to that you can also
set a time a future date and time when
your email will be set this is extremely
extremely helpful the next tool is email
game it seems very silly in some
respects because it's gamified but
you'll generally knock out your email
probably 40 50 % faster and the reason
for that is it doesn't allow you to look
at your inbox it takes you sequentially
through every email you can't just click
on I go I don't want to deal with that
right now mark is on red you can't do
that the next is to routinely go through
your inbox star things that are from
close family important contacts you
manage your life with say an accountant
or whatever it might be and then archive
all the rest with the assumption that if
it's important it's gonna come to you a
second time in the last recommendation I
would say is that you should not treat
email like a chat tool and whenever
possible you should use an augmenting
tool to handle that function my team and
I use slack for a lot of these
conversations I would additionally say
that just emptying your inbox does not
mean you've accomplished anything number
seven pre commit to one task with Thomas
Frank pre committing to a task is simply
building some sort of device that binds
you to finishing it before you actually
get started and to do this you can use
what are called commitment devices it's
why I use beeminder to ensure that I
create two things every week on my
website if you have some way of making
sure there's a consequence for not
getting your work done you're gonna be
more motivated to stay focused on that
work this can be as simple as writing
down that you're going to get X done in
30 minutes and if you don't finish
within 30 minutes you know that you've
failed
you've externalized that goal by writing
it down
and now that you failed it you're gonna
feel bad you could even do something
crazy like hiring a lady off Craigslist
to slap you in the face like many safety
did or you could stay within a realm of
sanity that's cool too
you can also pre commit to one task by
eliminating your ability to do anything
else during that time this is often
called the burnt ships technique and
it's in reference to an inaccurate but
still compelling story about Hernan
Cortes telling his men to burn their
ships before they attack the Aztecs the
motivation for doing this would have
been to keep his men focused on the task
because they had no other option they
couldn't go back and number eight the
last one before the bonus is plan your
day with marie forleo so no matter how
late at night you go before you wrap up
just take four minutes and really think
through everything that you have to get
done for the next day so here's how I
usually do it first thing I do is I open
up my calendar and I take a look at all
the appointments that I have for the
next day and the time that those
appointments will take like this one
o'clock I got a team call that last
thirty minutes three thirty I have a
marietv script review that'll take about
an hour and then I have a six thirty
spin class then I write down all the
projects and the tasks that I need to
get done and I give myself a little bit
of an estimate about how long I think
each project or task will take of course
these are estimates sometimes I get
things done faster and sometimes they
take longer but at least I get myself a
baseline to work off of nine to ten
thirty I am I'm gonna write a first
draft of a sales video script I'm gonna
give myself about 90 minutes then from
11:30 to 12:30 I'm gonna review my
social media schedule give myself an
hour for that and from 2:30 to 3:00 I'll
do a little email clear out and finally
I make a new little section at the
bottom of my notepad with personal
things that I need to handle for that
day for example get nanny a birthday
card and mail it that'll take me about
30 minutes order more kuma food all of
10 minutes and book a haircut for the
next month takes me about five minutes
boom that is it super simple so when I
do this it informs exactly when I need
to be at my desk and working which tells
me when I need to wake up to have enough
time to do my little morning routine and
get everything done without feeling
rushed
stressed the worst thing you can do is
wake up in the morning and go straight
to your computer and open up email and
then all of a sudden you're pretending
to work all day and at the end of the
day nothing important ever got done
nobody's perfect and of course not every
day goes as planned but this system
gives you the best chance possible and
making sure that your most important
projects get done especially if you have
an inconsistent schedule
now I've got a special bonus clip on
working smarter with Jack Ma but before
getting to that the question the day is
I'm curious what is your number one tip
that you have learned on how to work
smarter leave it down in the comments
below I'm really excited to find out
thank you guys for watching I believe in
you
I hope continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus
who works harder the people at eBay are
the people of Alibaba
it's sometimes you have not only have to
work how you have to work smart mm-hmm
so would you say you work smarter than I
pay I'd have to say yes right well so
far yeah so so far okay because because
I think you know we are pretty lucky
people and the people see you yeah you
work very high qu in this or that so
many people work very hard but they're
not that I told my team when we I'd pill
I asked a lot of people sitting there I
say you know one of you guys motovlog I
millionaires and so rich but 15 years
ago who are we
it's so difficult for us to hide people
15 years ago people who are not that bad
I said people can walk still walk on
sorry we hide them because nobody
believed internet nobody believed
internet and they join a company those
people who believe they're smart they
were had hunted by two the other company
set up their own company those people no
nobody go to head Huntingdon this state
today the big successful very key
reasons we exist will persist we never
give up we believe the dreams together
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple so
it would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]